what if i told you that worlds msi all
of riot games's world-class
industry-defining events were all run
out of what is essentially a nebulously
named technologically miraculous
briefcase or well series of briefcases
why
because they had to be you see for a
long time riot esports's remotely run
events were prone to disaster so were
those of most esports mind you but riot
had it especially bad because of just
how global they were riots tournaments
weren't just elite they were everywhere
i remember in vietnam one year we had to
get fiber and it ran into a manhole
cover and we just for curiosity looked
at where the fiber went it went into a
pool of water like greasy water so we're
like
this is frightening and because of that
they've also faced their fair share
of failures we feel at this point that
the internet is not stable and we do not
feel that it is fair to subject the
players you guys the audience to these
ongoing connectivity issues from
seemingly infinite silver scrapes loops
to the cobbling together of something
called
frankenservers there is no question that
professional league of legends has been
put through the ringer in fact on more
than one occasion
its production value has
been kind of a meme sadly even in the
years where things were like almost
perfect if there was one hiccup there
would be a thread about oh eu production
added again so in an effort to rectify
these issues once and for all
riot decided to revolutionize how their
events were orchestrated in the first
place
what's really cool is how they did it
you see at some point they realized that
in order to bring league to the world
they needed to bring it around the world
it would be like saying take facebook
and run it offline
[Applause]
okay so before we start executing last
hits with little to no latency do
yourselves a favor and capitalize on
this whole zero ping cisco sponsored
video by liking it
slapping the subscribe button and
turning on notifications
see how crispy and responsive those
clicks were alright now in order to
understand what the realm is and how
riot esports got to where it is today
you first need to understand what issues
it set out to solve
because if you were around back in the
day like i was and you saw league
esports when it was first starting out
you know
it was tough scenes yeah it was it was
rough um
the way i would describe it is no one
knew esports was going to be as big as
it is today and anyone who tells you
that they they did is is lying to you so
if you can imagine trying to build
for the future where every year the
needs and the expectations double or
triple
it's really hard to stay up to date and
stay current and keep the technology uh
to the state of the game that my kings
and queens is mr scott adametz global
head of technology on riot's esports
senior leadership team now thanks to our
friends over at cisco hashtag ad i was
able to sit down with scott and talk for
a solid hour about the tech side of riot
esports
and well the fact that it used to be
kind of a dumpster fire now again to be
fair so was the tech side of like every
esport it's just that riots was kind of
famously off to a rough start if you go
back about 10 years you got to remember
league of legends when it was first
launched did not have offline play it
had no capability to do a lan event
it was only after esports kind of
arguably exploded
that they realized that there was going
to be a need for local
play that does not rely on or is not
dependent on the internet and for riot
it actually came in the form of a pretty
public failure
that's going to be the presenter they're
going to drop down he's going to go in
there fccf have to use
his uh
[Applause]
[Music]
to this day season two of worlds is
warmly remembered for its
unprecedented hype incredible cinderella
story
and just the sea of crashes delays and
remakes that plagued it by the 25 minute
mark during a war kill cheer the
internet crashed bottom lane is going to
be pretty much even so the lanes at the
moment are very much
all the players were disconnected and
the stream went down oh and let's not
forget the hours upon hours of generic
annoyingly catchy dubstep that not only
haunted its technical difficulty screens
but has since cemented itself as the
literal anthem of league
[Music]
so what did riot learn from that finals
well for starters that running an
offline event entirely online was uh
pretty scuffed the question was whether
they could take league out of the ether
and like stick it on a hard drive after
the big failure a lot of contingent
within riot between the game devs and
the early esports team which was very
small realized that if we are going to
have to rely on the internet to do these
shows
and we can't rely on the internet being
completely stable we need another
solution so on a spectrum it'd be like
all online
they went all offline they said
the internet absolutely no internet
connection required for this to run the
best part
is the name they came up with
the realm
yes
it is
it's called the realm that's the
official name the realm if you had to
think of it
is everything you would need technically
to run
an event to the scale of riot esports
that's network servers storage and all
the way down to game servers the the
actual uh equipment that runs the
binaries that allow you to play
competitive league physically if you
were to come to us to a show and go into
the bowels of the building it's actually
a room
and it even has a little name badge that
says the realm and it's it's
one of the coolest little rooms because
it's so non-descript you wouldn't know
if the door was closed that that is the
heartbeat the the nerve center of the
entire show if something happened to
that room the show's done what's even
cooler is how they built it league had
grown exponentially since release and it
was becoming apparent to riot that the
esports side was quite simply being
outpaced the thing is they didn't have a
ton of resources to improve it so they
decided to get creative
so what the early scrappy members of the
esports technology group that i support
at riot they would go to those data
centers and they would kind of beg
borrow and arguably steal the servers
that were going to be e-wasted so these
these were
in no uncertain terms trash and some of
them were working perfectly some were
broken some had missing pieces some were
no hard drives you could you name it it
was just a smattering of things that
probably should have gone into the
recycling pile but esports at the time
didn't have a big tech budget because
again no one knew that this was going to
be a thing going forward so you know we
hoped but no one was preparing for 10
years of this now there was also the
issue of running broadcasts remotely
which as anyone who was a frequent
viewer of the eu lcs when it was first
starting out will absolutely attest to
had long been a big problem for riot
first up welcome gentlemen
congratulations what are your general
thoughts after your first week missy
missy missy
i was more nervous about the rocket game
than the fnatic game and i have good
news folks
it's time for some league of legends
clap there you go yeah
[Applause]
thank you audience
[Applause]
we need connectivity to do these events
and it's not a small amount of
connectivity remember that we're
actually producing these amazing events
like worlds for the past five seven
years almost all the msis and all the
regional regional events remotely and
all we really need to do is bring back
the raw feeds the signals the camera
feeds the observers like bring back just
the raw materials that we use to create
the awesome presentations and shows that
riot's known for
but to do that requires an immense
amount of bandwidth and that's where you
start to hear about dark fiber at the
beginning of every show day we'd find
out how many strands of dark fiber do we
have i believe at the time we had three
or four and there'd be show days where
they're like guys we're down to one dark
fiber like if this goes down we lose
everything so what exactly is
dark fiber
well
as it turns out
i have no
earthly idea do you understand that we
started this show so i could talk about
stretched res like i don't even know
what bitrate is or how my freaking mouse
works and now they want me to talk about
dark
matter
okay look the city is flying we're
fighting an army of robots
and i have a bow and arrow none of this
makes sense thankfully as i'm sure you
all know i have access to someone who
knows
way more about this stuff than i do so
i'll let him explain well well well
dimitri what would you do without me
here to carry you through
oh
oh sorry sorry did you think i meant you
oh
yikes uh no no i was referring to an
actual expert
god that felt good
here to spit said science is rahul para
mejoran a principal technical marketing
engineer for data center networking at
cisco who named it the dark fiber and
why was it called the dark fiber
especially when
you know when light traverses through
that fiber right giving again an analogy
of of
going from one place to another you have
you could take the train you could you
could drive on the car or you could fly
you know when you fly you're gonna get
there the quickest now think of uh
connectivity as multiple ways through
which asia can communicate to the united
states right it can go through a
satellite link or it can go through
multiple service providers and then you
have your own dedicated connection
through which you can establish this
communication in a nutshell that gives
you
the best connectivity which means you
know the most
bandwidth low latency
everything that you would need right to
to introduce the game or to produce or
to relay the broadcast to viewers all
around the world right and now the guy
who oh whoa whoa no we can't use that
title card when it's just me and dimitri
sure i'm definitely the one who knows
what he's talking about
rahul knows more than both of us put
together
so just to give you guys and dimitri
some context the companies that
originally laid the fiber optic internet
infrastructure laid way more cables than
isps would actually use so the extras
known as dark fiber are rentable by
event organizers if you're a streamer
you routinely or not so routinely for
some of us send a video feed to your
streaming platform of choice through
your run-of-the-mill internet service
provider and it seems to get there fine
so why would anyone need their own
dedicated fiber internet connection
there are a couple of reasons but the
first is distance when you hit start
streaming in obs the packets containing
your video and audio are going to a
twitch server that at least relatively
speaking is not very far from you this
creates very little lag time between
your horrific misplay and your chat
calling you a bot but if you're riot
games sending those packets from say
korea back to a studio in la the extra
distance and additional routing are
going to greatly increase the lag time
in your production the more pressing
reason though
is stability even if you're ludwig
sending your high def audio and video to
a twitch server isn't going to tax your
internet service providers
infrastructure that much for riot who
are presumably sending multiple very
high bitrate feeds whose packets would
be passing through exponentially more
routing points are bound to run into
exponentially more problems as well
since every new routing point is another
potential network problem the solution
is just to cut out as many as possible
and get what is in essence a direct
connection back to their studio of
choice i hope that i can extend this bit
of knowledge is an olive branch to you
dimitri i know we've both said some
things we didn't mean but i think it's
time we let bygones be bygones let's
face it we're ultimately smarter
together than we are apart
[Laughter]
are you serious needless to say it
wasn't so much riot who faced the brunt
of the community's frustrations but the
actual human faces who despite working
tirelessly to promote and personalize
these products had literally nothing to
do with powering them i think the nature
of being
one of the on-air talent crew is that
when something goes wrong people are
going to write to you on twitter and on
reddit and instagram and everything and
that's that's totally fine also but i
was in person at the studio every single
day i know how hard everyone worked and
how hard everyone wanted it to be good
and to be perfect and always something
kind of went wrong that we we couldn't
foresee and then it didn't get fixed and
it turned into this whole thing and
sadly even in the years where things
were like almost perfect if there was
one hiccup there would be a thread about
oh eu production added again i mean it
was very difficult to deal with because
fan sentiment back in 2013
was still very
i'm going to use the word juvenile
the fans the viewers the people who are
consuming the content
didn't really grasp the scale of it
didn't really understand the nuances of
it and a lot of people that watch our
content and and younger viewers
also don't yet understand television
broadcast or sports broadcast back in
the day we regularly had discussions and
meetings around what we could do to
mitigate the negative sentiment and
what we could do to educate the viewers
and try to to process it
but it took a very very long time for
that to turn now despite making massive
pioneering strides with the realm and
running tons of tournaments without a
hitch
riot knew that it was far from perfect
in fact it was at worlds 2018 where
their worst nightmare
got dangerously close to becoming a
reality one of the
the hairiest stories that i will tell
you is going into worlds 2018
in korea uh that was the kda show up
until the i want to say the night before
um
the start of the event we could not run
a game
we could not stably run a single game of
league of legends it became alarmingly
apparent
that something needed to change i think
the the team
knew that that an investment was needed
but it's really difficult to ask for
that level of investment
when you're used to
kind of making the best with what you
can find so it took some fresh eyes and
someone coming in and saying no this is
this is worth it for us to think about
long term and invest for the future if
it's worth doing let's do it right i'm
gonna put myself in scott's shoes right
i want to be able to you know
very easily set up new games make sure
that i'm able to host the tournament
anywhere in the world not not having to
worry about
landing there and finding out whether
it's going to work or not right and that
is how cisco entered the server what got
us the first 10 years of esports
wouldn't have gotten us the next ten
this is how cisco came to be affiliated
with with riot games and league of
legends esports is we searched out for a
tech partner that would help us on that
journey to take what used to be e-waste
and
found and repurposed gear and think
about it what would we do if we had the
next 10 years to plan now you know i can
say that we've been able to provide
everything that they would need so that
they don't first and foremost run into
any issues that they did but also be
rest assured that no matter how the
technology changes in the future they
don't have to come back to the white
board and figure out hey how do i now
accommodate some you know all of these
new things today the realm enables riot
to both run their tournaments without a
hitch and offer competitors a
of the art on stage experience what
started as an all online disaster has
since become the platinum standard for
crispy painless inputs in esports
playing on land or playing at zero ping
is just it's different um there are
certain actions i'm told that are not
possible to play at latency but are
possible in a lan environment um and
it's down to timing
heading over here okay are you going to
take a bit of damage but jinja pushed on
a half hp stun comes in on a scout and
as they still unleash in canada
let's go oh
my word and yes i made sure to ask scott
whether this same technology could be
compatible with riot's other ips as well
who knows maybe in a couple years we
won't just be jamming out in project a
at zero ping but project l everything
that we have built we have built in mind
to be agnostic to the game so nothing
we've built for league is specific to
league when we built new infrastructure
we built new infrastructure for the next
10 years of riot esports i'm happy to
say the valorant events the lan events
have benefited from the same
infrastructure so they are at zero ping
envy come on you gotta make this happen
chronicle he walks through and destroys
envy
three back to back frags and it might be
four in a second he's on the chopping
block gambit have made it to 12. so then
it's true competition right between
player a and player b because you want
to make sure that there's fairness that
everyone gets a fair share of of uh you
know the same
experience so it's then it's up to their
skills as to who who does better than
the other i never thought i'd be telling
riveting tales about server
infrastructure but
i gotta say the story of how the realm
came to be and what it's not only doing
variety sports but presumably all
esports is super cool
i for one cannot wait to see where it
goes from here
that's how i know ryan is a zoomer when
we play siege because he says he's
knocked when he lights a guy
that's rough
what it's the fortnite thing you know
like when you break armor or like when
you not i know isn't it disgusting isn't
it just absolutely repulsive
isn't it just repulsive golden
i knocked i knocked one
it's lit it's lit
he's lit
tagged maybe tags because tagged is the
oldest form yeah tagged is fine tagged
is fine
that's a cs term yes tagged
that is
he's knocked one shot i'll take one one
shot's fine he's one he's literally one
if you say he's one
he says like 80 health
easily 80 health if you say he's
literally one then it's like okay he's
actually like 20 or below what
he's zoomers bro he's knocked what the
[ __ ] is that right